when you're talking positioning
don are you talking positioning almost
like the blue ocean strategy positioning
or do you have a different uh way of
looking at positioning
well blue ocean is a that's a great book
and a great thought mine is
my positioning when i think about
positioning i literally think about the
words that you use
to position yourself in the market and
uh there's a formula that i use to go
through that so building a story brand
probably the reason i'm on your
your podcast and we could probably talk
for for two weeks straight patrick but
the reason i'm here is to talk about
positioning and what that looks like
we help people clarify their message and
we do that
using the elements of story the ancient
story structure that
existed before aristotle but aristotle
was the first to write about it in a
book called poetics
and so it's 2500 years old we some
adaptation of this story structure
the reason i like story in order to
captivate an audience is because the
average human brain spends about 30
percent of its time daydreaming 30
of its time that's actually a survival
mechanism it's your brain
saying there's nothing that i'm
encountering right now that can help me
survive
so we're going to take a break and i'll
check back in with reality later
when i think my brain needs to help me
survive
except when you're watching a movie if
you're watching a movie or reading a
book or watching a television series
your brain will not daydream it will
actually pay attention for 90 minutes
two hours a whole weekend
it is the only tool on the planet that
can get somebody to pay attention
it's fascinating so it's worth studying
i think
story and how it works because every
little plot
point that we study actually gives us a
fascinating
business paradigm shift that we can use
to make more money in our company so
let me go through the formula for you
and just give you a fly
over version of of what it is uh in
every story
first of all stories are very formulaic
and a lot of people don't know that
but uh there are basically about 35 plot
points that happen in a story
there are only seven stories that ever
get told in the theater
if you know what those stories are you
know where the movie's going
uh my wife hates going to the movies
with me because i elbow her and say that
guy dies in 31 minutes
he normally does uh they're just they're
just formulaic
the beautiful thing is what that means
is over the 2500 years
story specialists have figured out how
to captivate an audience's attention
so one of the hardest things for us to
do as small business owners
is get people's attention and keep it so
let's look at how a story works and see
how it can help us
the very first thing that happens in a
story i'm gonna go through seven
uh critical plot points that happen in
every single movie that you'll go see
uh the first is a character you have a
character who shows up on screen
and what you've gotta do as a
screenwriter is you've gotta you've
gotta
you've gotta figure out what that
character wants because that defines the
story
the character has to want to disarm the
bomb the character has to want to win
the championship the character has to
want to marry the girl
it has to be really specific so there
are two mistakes that amateur
screenwriters make
and they're the same mistakes that
business leaders make the first is
they are too vague in defining
what it is that their customer wants so
if if um patrick if i said hey let's
skip the rest of this interview
there's a movie down the street it's
about a guy looking for fulfillment
is that interesting to you at all not at
all
okay let me tempt you a little better
patrick let's skip this interview
there's a movie down the street
liam another of liam neeson's daughters
has been kidnapped
is that more tempting or more tempting
more tempting
well the reason is it's clear and so if
if we are elusive or vague
we can't captivate somebody's attention
and here's what i mean by that
you know i study websites for a living
if i go to your website and you have
something like
uh trust is the commodity we exchange
you're not going to sell anything
because it's so vague
it's you know it doesn't say what you
offer it doesn't tell me what problem
you solve
we've got to know so it can't be vague
or elusive
the other problem is we will define too
many things that the customer wants
we want to put all 27 of our revenue
streams up on
the the main page but if i took you to a
movie if we went to a movie and jason
bourne wanted to know who he really was
he wanted to lose 30 pounds he wanted to
run a marathon he wanted to
marry the girl he's thinking about
adopting a cat
i've put too many plot points in that
movie and i'm going to lose the audience
uh it's just not going to work so we
have to define something the customer
wants
the next thing we have to do is our hero
in the story
has to have a problem there has to be
something that is
challenging them in fact a story without
a problem
can't hook the audience you know if i
said uh
a buddy of mine wanted to play or was in
la and he got a call from some friends
and they said come down to the beach
we're playing volleyball and he walked
down to the beach and
they were all his best friends they
started playing volleyball and the game
ended in
tai and then one of them said i'm hungry
and said there's some tacos across the
street the tacos happen to be on sale
how long can i go into this story
without
boring you what's going to happen is
very quickly if we don't have a problem
the audience is going to begin to
daydream and and that's what's happening
with most of us in our businesses here's
the business paradigm shift there
if you're not talking about your
customers problems
you are not selling anything and your
business is not going to grow
the only reason your customer is going
to your website or calling your sales
rep back or walking into your retail
establishment
is because they are trying to solve a
problem when you make it very
clear what problem you solve you attract
customers in fact i say to sales people
all the time
you're not actually trying to sell
anything what you're trying to do is
you're trying to connect this
product to a problem that your customer
has
and when the synapses fire and they see
this product as the resolution to the
problem
that is when they are going to buy it so
you've got to figure out what that
problem is
you've got to talk about it you've got
to say this is a painful problem and
nobody should have to deal with this
therefore you should buy this product
and when you do that
you're actually going to sell a lot more
product so we've got to have the problem
next
the third element is the guide guide
g-u-i-d-e
when we represent our business our
product we want you to play the guide
in the story don't play the hero you
play the hero in your personal life
but when you're representing a brand or
you're selling a product
you play the guide and what does the guy
do the guide helps the hero win the day
so if you're not listening to anything
else on this podcast hear me say this
never play the hero in the story
always play the guide when it comes to
representing your brand what does that
mean
well when you play the hero in the story
first of all
if i say if you say don tell me every
business i say well you know we're
trying to make 15 million this year
we're trying to increase our great
places
to work metric and we want to have our
fourth quarter revenue be double what it
was last year
what you hear me saying is that i'm a
hero in a story
well if i'm a hero in a story and you're
a hero in a story
we're in separate stories so the second
we play the hero on the story we remove
ourselves from our customers story
that's so powerful what you just said
right can you say that one more time
that was so powerful
i hope i'm not i don't mean to interrupt
i just want to make sure they cut what
you just said right there
when you play the hero in the story you
remove yourself from your customer story
your customers walking to the room
saying i need a guide
to help me solve a problem and win the
day and when they recognize that you're
the hero
they go okay well you're a hero and i'm
a hero
nice to meet you would you move out of
the way i'm looking for a guide who can
help me